[Music]
i'm jennifer walters
i'm a normal lawyer
well not that normal these
transformations are triggered by anger
and fear don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me when i'm angry
how are you feeling
right now
what are you feeling
that it's really difficult to be around
people
because they just want me to be better
[Music]
so you're not able to
share what you're feeling with other
people
[Music]
[Music]
believe me when i tell you
you don't want to see my buddy mad
you haven't seen how relentless he is
when he sees wren
[Music]
this is not a cartoon this is the real
world
and yet some of us still
don't die with bullets
some of us can still bend steel
you all right
[Music]
kamala let's talk about you
it's not really the brown girls from
jersey city
you saved the world
maybe now they do
i got this right totally
[Music]
[Music]
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
the voice
in your head
it devours you
[Music]
[Music]
you